un enfant de 14 ans est mort quelques
heures après avoir mangé la chips la
plus piquante du monde un défi populaire
sur Tik Tok voici ce qu'il s'est passé
alors ce garçon il vivait dans la ville
américaine de Worcester dans le
Massachusetts et il est décédé le 1er
septembre selon la mère de l'enfant
interrogé par NBC son fils à manger la
chips la plus piquante du monde qu'un
camarade de classe lui avait donné le
garçon de 14 ans a été pris en charge
par l'infirmière de l'école qui a
prévenu sa mère par téléphone plus tard
dans la journée l'enfant se sentait
mieux selon sa mère mais il s'est
évanoui vers 16h30 il a alors été
transporté à l'hôpital où il a été
déclaré mort quelques minutes plus tard
une enquête a été ouverte par la police
locale et une autopsie est en cours pour
rappel le One ship challenge est un défi
populaire depuis plusieurs années mais
relancer ces derniers mois sur Tik Tok
aux États-Unis notamment mais aussi en
France le concept est simple manger une
chips extrêmement piquante et filmer les
réactions selon NBC la chips que le
jeune homme a mangé et celle vendu à 10
dollars par Paquis elle contient les
deux piments les plus relevés au monde
le Carolina Reaper et le Naga Viper sur
le site internet qui commercialise la
chips il est indiqué que la chips doit
rester hors de porter des enfants la
chips doit être consommée par des
adultes